on va s'intéresser aux 40 ans du centre
paris ouest oui voilà c'est l'occasion
donc de revenir sur le développement de
cet espace économique je vous propose de
regarder ce sujet qui ont retracé
l'historique et puis on retrouvera juste
après michel charpin le président de
l'association de cette zone d'activités
paris ouest une zone industrielle et
commerciale de 130 hectares sur maurepas
et coignières 50 industrie 70
établissements de commerce et de loisirs
et plus de vingt restaurants et hôtels
en quarante ans d'existence parc a bien
changé
1973 création de la zone d'activités à
l'époque eduardo par le père fondateur
de paris ouest souhaite développer une
zone exclusivement industriel
thyssenkrupp et achète seront les
premières entreprises à s'installer
mais les difficultés commencent pour
occuper les espaces vacants et qu'il y
avait une demande d'installation sur la
zone paris ouest il fallait l'accord de
l'état par le biais de la datar ce
retard est évidemment on incitait les
entreprises qui souhaitaient s'installer
sur la zone paris ouest conlon on les
diriger vers saint quentin en yvelines
ce qui fait que c'était une concurrence
tout à fait déloyal parce que là c'est
zac c'était une société complètement
privée et qui n'avait pas de fonds de
l'état ce n'était pas une société
d'économie mixte étaient totalement
privées car paris ouest c'est un peu
l'histoire d'une bataille sans fin et le
premier conflit pour maurepas et
coignières avec la ville nouvelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
faute d'industrie la zone se tourner
vers les activités commerciales
le parc prend officiellement le nom de
paris ouest en 1986 leclerc s'installe
un supermarché de 15 mille mètres carrés
au lieu des trois mille prévus à
l'époque la mairie de coignières ne voit
pas d'un bon oeil cette concurrence pour
les commerçants de sa ville la guerre
est lancée contre le directeur du
magasin je suis habité race donc mettez
de la publicité partout dancoisne hier
sur la route nationale surtout des actes
et ils en inondé le paysage ce qui était
interdit par le publier le règlement
publicité se voit l'air d'une part et
interdit également par la dde le long de
la route nationale 10 dans verizon monde
mon bon droit d'arracher tout ça ce qui
était commun fort amusant c'est que
c'est mes employés municipaux qui
collecter toutes ces fléchettes qui les
mettait dans une benne et monsieur
abihssira sa laideur racheter je dirais
pour les remettre de nouveau sur le
terrain aujourd'hui la paix est revenue
aux espaces industriel et commercial
s'est ajouté un espace loisirs dès 1996
3 aujourd'hui bien délimitées nous avons
réussi d'une zone qui était aux deux
cinquièmes
vide en 1990 avoir une zone qui est
plein qu'à 95% pour les 5% restants il
faudra attendre de savoir si oui ou non
le projet d'installation d'un cinéma
multiplexe et valider
les 40 ans du centre paris ouest à
maurepas qui nous intéresse à présente
exactement michel château bonjour donc
on vient de voir un petit historique de
paris ouest vous ne voulez vous n'avez
pas connu à ses débuts mais ça fait tout
de même quelques années que vous êtes
donc maintenant président de l'az a
comme à un petit mot peut-être sur la za
coma pour qu'on comprenne la zac cobas
et là c'est une association syndicale
libre donc complètement privée qui
regroupe les propriétaires fonciers qui
le soit propriétaire du bâtiment et de
l'activité ou qui souhaitent simplement
propriétaire des murs la zac au maquis
et a étendu son nom à paris ouest depuis
quelques années et a aussi compétences
surtout toutes les voiries tous les tous
les déplacements en fait toute la
mobilité sur la distribution d'eau sur
les évacuations fin tous les réseaux y
compris le réseau d'éclairage public on
va essayer d y décision en fait
finalement commune vous avez voulu
conserver le mode de fonctionnement de
départ je passe c'est à dire que quand
on crée une organisation comme ça qui
est fondée sur une loi ancienne de 1865
pour la changer c'est très difficile
parce qu'il faut
une pratiquement l'unanimité des
propriétaires et en général on n'obtient
pas donc c'est pour ça que cette
organisation est très pérenne et comme
elle fonctionne bien personne ne s'en
plaint ça continue lorsqu'on ce qu'on
voyait en fait dans le sujet c'est au
final c'était à la base une zone
industrielle qui se voulait uniquement
industrielle aujourd'hui donc on a une
partie industrie une partie commerce une
partie loisirs
finalement est-ce que vous vous êtes
satisfait de cette évolution si vous
voulez au départ c'était le rêve des
trente glorieuses donc on mettait de
l'industrie partout y compris près de
paris on a dû se revenir un réalisme
deux clubs est de constater que les
industries ne venaient plus alors comme
le disait dans le reportage dominique
pestel on ne faisait pas ce qu'on
voulait c'est pas parce que c'est une
zone privée de gestion privée quand est
ce qu'on voulait puisque les
implantations était décidé à paris à la
datar aujourd'hui c'est très différent
mais il ya encore des demandes
d'autorisations administratives
par l'état et donc il ya un moment mais
on s'est dit le commerce prend son essor
il faut prendre le virage ça n'a pas été
facile sur le plan politique en
particulier à maurepas parce que la
municipalité n'était pas pour donc le
maire georges mougeot à eux devraient
dans ce sens et ensuite aujourd'hui tout
le monde est bien d'accord par contre
paris ouest le territoire de paris ouest
est organisée il est organisé qu'il ya
maintenant un plan local d'urbanisme on
ne veut pas et des commerces partout on
veut des commerces suffisamment
important et non pas des petits
commerces qui ferait concurrence aux
artisans comme le prédécesseur de
centre-ville à mort paul y en a aussi à
maurepas donc on ne veut pas ce type de
concurrence lors d'organiser exactement
ces dernières années on a perçu village
des loisirs justement à l'image c'est
pour ça que je suis vous êtes satisfait
briois si le peuple
est évident et donc n'importe qui peut
vous êtes satisfait de la réussite ou
non de ce site alors la réussite elle
pourrait encore être améliorée par le
venue d'un complexe cinématographique
c'est une grande bataille depuis 1995
que la préfecture l'a refusé à plusieurs
reprises que les impasses en commission
prochain brody national cdn espère une
en appel un puisque la commission
départementale a refusé une fois en 2010
l'a acceptée mais avec une majorité
insuffisante cette année 2012 et nous
l'an dernier en 2012 et nous avons fait
appel donc on espère enfin les arguments
qui avait été opposé et auquel nous
avions les objections auquel nous avions
répondu en particulier les pistes
cyclables accès convaincre aulas une
objection vous n'avez pas évoquer hamon
a parlé hier en plateau ce sera c'est
très rapide le responsable du ciné sept
cinémas d'elancourt un qui va d'ailleurs
est ouverte au début avril rappelez vous
êtes à trois kilomètres de distance et
que ça va être un petit peu compliqué
pour la cohabitation des deux ensembles
alors je suis pas venu pour faire un
débat là-dessus non tous les deux sauté
sur mais c'était très gm parce qu'il ya
des gens qui d'abord ceux qui iraient à
ce cinéma paris ouest ne sont pas que
des gens ne meurent pas et où
d'elancourt il ya aussi d'autres villes
à coignières
joueurs qu'on a fait c'est qu'ils sont
intéressés par ce complexe et les
quartiers qui sont proches de
paris-ouest eau des habitants qui sont
extrêmement intéressé par un sit in
males retrouve il ya de la place pour
tout le monde tout à fait sur ce fil
avait alors simplement le cinéma
pourquoi nous y tenons parce que il
remplirait un bon rôle dans cet espace
consacré aux loisirs l'idée qui avait
présidé à cette installation c'était
quoi on arrive à paris ouest on y fait
ses achats dans les
différents magasins on a des garages si
on veut faire un trait sa voiture et on
la base de loisirs rien on a des
restaurants on a des espaces de loisirs
pour y faire jouer ses enfants ou pour
même si des temps ça serait pour le
chiffre d'affaires global de la balance
des paiements
en dessous on compte combien d'emplois
hongrie 1000 à peu près avec le
dénombrement des emplois c'est un
exercice difficile c'est environ 8000
alors ça fluctue au gré de l'activité
économique générale bien entendu au gré
de l'arrivée des départs l'entreprise
puisqu'il suffit qu'on se met entre deux
pour qu'il baisse un petit peu c'est de
l'ordre de huit mille francs tout cas au
dessus de 8000 et on dit on disons
environ 6000 côté maurepas et 2000 à
2500 côté coignières actuellement mais
c'est en train de monter puisque on a
des entreprises qui embauchent en ce
moment paris ouest on citait je ne sais
plus dans le reportage l'exemple de
style design qui remportent des succès
si l'entreprise industriel design
industriel qui remportent des succès à
l'international des gros succès il ya
par exemple l'entreprise thyssenkrupp
qui envisage de regrouper des équipes à
maurepas et donc l'emploi est en
progression sur cette zone d'activités
ce qui ne veut pas dire que le chômage
baisse à mort passe avec un peu dommage
et pour conclure en tête revenir juste
sur sur les dates de qui célèbre en fait
un petit peu ses 40 ans il y a donc on a
réussi l'exploit de faire venir les gens
pour qu'ils se parlent entre eux voilà
c'est la première fois qu'on y arrive on
a réussi à
organiser une connexion et du coup
sirènes des salles est bien pris par le
temps je suis désolé il y a donc une
exposition c'est donc il ya plusieurs
événements il ya une tombola commercial
il ya un exercice qui est fait par les
élèves des collèges et des lycées sur
l'avenir sur l'avenir et il y a
effectivement une une exposition de
photos sur le passé le présent le futur
merci à vous merci clair merci nous
avons chronique de l'écho comme chaque
jeudi c'est la fin de cette édition du 7
8 je vous retrouverai mardi en direct
dès 18 heures ce week-end de vendredi à
lundi c'est catherine gâteau pour
l'édition du week-end de revenir sur
tous les sujets qui nous ont intéressés
depuis le début de la semaine merci de
nous avoir suivis excellente soirée